machen sie einfach irgendwas rein
es war ein kindergeburtstag willkommen
bei einem video
seit vorarlberg heute ich weiß nicht ob
ich mich gut hört aber ich denke schon
oder bestes contest ja welches kam jetzt
schon wieder eine woche kein video also
wirklich fasste woche grund dafür ich
musste noch meine letzte hausarbeit
fertigschreiben für meine uni aber ich
bin jetzt fertig jetzt habe ich endlich
mal wieder frei und kann mich ein
bisschen darauf konzentrieren wie man
denn am besten sechs hätten menüs im
wander stellt meine absoluten
lieblingsbeschäftigungen wie ihr wisst
nicht was ich habe heute wirklich was
besonderes überlegt ich meine so was
habe ich auf youtube zumindest noch nie
gesehen schon besonders nun richtig gut
was sie den und somit auf jeden fall wie
viele von euch wissen ich bin ja
eigentlich gar nicht so der papst für
mensch nein
als ich meine spezielle dieses
mcdonald's oder burger king fastfood
weißt du das finde ich echt nicht so gut
und wenn ich dann zum beispiel mal bei
mcdonald bin dann esse ich echt immer
nur einen happy meal weil mehr will ich
davon nicht essen so dass kulanz und
happy meals es ist ja eigentlich auch
etwas anderes drin also wenn man jetzt
nicht weiß was bei dem anderen im happy
drin ist man kann es ja auch nicht
bestimmen genau ist ein richtiges und
ich bin jetzt gerade halt wieder in köln
und hat hunger und habe mir diese krasse
challenge verlegt weil ich eh noch ein
video drehen wollte ich glaube ich habe
schon wieder viel zu lange aber ich muss
das jetzt hier erst mal kurz erklären
also es geht im prinzip darum jeder von
uns hat jetzt drei apps und jeder kurze
szene wo ich die bestellt haben hallo
ich hätte gern einer 6 happy meals geht
das ja genau 6 das ist ganz egal da kann
alles also ist egal
genau alle ganz egal
machen sie einfach irgendwas rhein ist
wie ein kindergeburtstag können sie auch
irgendwas reinmachen
das wäre schon danke er ohne witz die
dachten sich auch so welcher vogel
bestellt wirklich sechs happy meals ja
ich damit zweiter werde ich schon ein
bisschen angeguckt aber gut es war ja
nur für kinder geburtstag überraschen
genau der hat hier ihren über das rein
gestellt als ich ist entweder
cheeseburger haben bürger was heißt ich
keine ahnung
also ich denke kommission über die
getränk ihr könnt das jetzt von eurer
seite aussehen aber weg wir jetzt hier
zum beispiel nicht sehen ob das jetzt
hier cola oder fanta ist also ich kann
es bei dir sehen und so bei mir nicht
weil du kannst du nicht mal lecker da
weil man kann die farbe dass sie also du
musst jetzt gleich sagen ob ihr
cheeseburger hamburger oder chicken
gestern sind ob der ketchup oder mayo
weiß oder sich saurer soße
ich habe das getränk fanta sprite oder
cola und als nachtisch gab es entweder
frucht quatsch keine ahnung das ist
dieses rote kreuz und als absolut
spielzeug muss zu sagen entweder junge
oder mädchen und betrieben punkte als
der krieg wenn das richtig ist nicht so
ein punkt würde das ist ganz wichtig wir
fangen jetzt jeder art zum beispiel ich
mit dem sie mit dem hammer kommen das
ganze immer so ein mist selbst und die
sache wie man richtig errät da gibt es
einen punkt für und der der vorrunde
mehr punkt hat kriegt halt dann das
hätte ich mir von anderen auch meister
das heißt wenn es ganz schlecht laufen
würde das war am ende der 6
ich hoffe ihr habt das prinzip
verstanden wer am ende die meisten
hätten ist hat gewonnen und jetzt
kommt's theorie und guck mal sexuell
er sagt du hast du wieder herstellen ich
würde mich machen
ja ihr habt noch neuen mitspieler moment
gewissen portion gesprochen hatte kommen
einfach hier in die mitte ich hoffe ihr
könnt sehen ich fange jetzt mit dem wir
ganz außen an die ganzen kann man ja
okay also ich sage es ist ja eh drinnen
commerce ketchup vater mädchenspielzeug
und worte fand dann siehst du nein man
kann das doch nicht sehen darf seine
spieler gucken musste dabei guckt sie
ist das ist schon breit ich habe mich
als spielzeuge sagt ein punkt zwei
punkte
das habe ich auch gesagt dass zählte gar
nicht wo ist das spielzeug 123 punkte
nicht mehr nur pommes hamburger und
gäste dann müssen wir den richtigen mann
nochmals geld ist juri disqualifiziert
ich sage jungs verstärkt einreichen da
jetzt wird die city kann das bereichen
chicken nuggets wieso ist der ketscher
tor weiß ich zwar nicht gespielt nie
sehr wild cats also was habe ich jetzt
ein punktespiel zu erreichen ein kommt
cola ok lassen wir geld zwei punkte und
kommen
das ist doch sagen zwei punkte nicht so
zum jahr
1 0 punkte
alex einmal wird so harry hat diesen
drei hätten wir jetzt für mich denke
sowieso leute erste runde ging natürlich
an welches gedacht ja wir kommen zur
zweiten runde
ich würde sagen jetzt doch mal so dass
auch noch rund 65 meter und ich habe
schon wieder was ist das denn für ein
scheiß da gibts doch der ist es dann
punkte ab zu bieten vielleicht sollte
man das alles nicht
damit rollten ja pommes und ketchup ich
habe jetzt auch einzeln und schickt
eigentlichen wir kannten ihn gedrängt
ach so ja fand schließlich einen punkt
letztes jahr war ich sagt jungs
spielzeug geschenkt sage ich ich sage
diesmal ist hoffentlich ketchup dabei
und ich selbst hieß bürgermeister ruft
okay das schon mal falsch komm jetzt und
hamburger verwehrt zeitpunkt oder ich
habe junge spielzeug für street- und was
hast du gesagt hätte was
nur zwei punkte für juli und jetzt kommt
der oberliga tags und nachts schnell
daran ob die leute passt auf hamburger
frucht quatsch wiso plus s.com ist circa
ähnliche und sperrte es geht ja doch so
richter 2 und roger mario okay ein punkt
für mir das wetter hielt regelrecht habe
ich gesagt die zwei punkte aber ich das
gesagt jungs spielzeit drei punkte aber
ich lese gesagt doch natürlich mal vier
punkte
der hat doch macht er nun nach jetzt ein
cheeseburger gemacht heldt nein jetzt
haben wir sowieso sagt hamberger von man
auswählen
ja ist bei ihrer moya okay so ging alex
hat mal wieder 1 234 punkte
viel spaß beim 6 1 jetzt ihr kriegt nix
leute das war eine geniale also für die
idee kann man doch auf jeden fall schon
mal daumen nach oben geben
es hat auch gerne bei judo und maria
bürgern vorbei so dass morgen wieder
morgen uns wieder ein echt cooles video
was vielleicht auch etwas mehr
durchgeplant ist als das hier aber als
40 und wollten wir natürlich auch ins
gras
das war wasser ist eine drei pokémon